i want to start with congratulations on
afterparty i'm sure you're hearing that
from everybody uh it's what we call real
good i really
and that's the official term real good
yeah it's just this is real good i uh
i'm so i saw the seven episodes and not
the eighth so i'm going to be i'm
sitting here just wondering who the hell
killed you know xavier and i will not
find out for probably a month and a half
which is not
not the best but whatever so i want to
know they haven't shown me the eighth
episode i have no idea who did it i'm
confident that uh uh you know but let's
move past that if someone has actually
never seen anything that you've done
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why
wow what a great question it's funny
because my instinct would probably say
john ralphio because i'm a nerd for uh
chronological order
like when i watch marvel movies again
early lord of the rings i'm never
skipping to the return of the king you
start with the fellowship and you work
your way through it so um i would say
you know you know it might be nice i
would go to maybe middle ditch and
schwartz just because then it shows you
improv and for me that's what that's how
i started doing improv and i'm really
proud that i was able to get an improv
special on
the air and i'm proud of the episodes
and the content in that so uh that and
then probably john ralphio um because
those are like john ralphio is very much
the first thing that kind of made me
be able to get other roles
a hundred percent um uh when you got
cast how much did chris tell you like
did chris tell you from the get-go
here's who did it like how much
information did he tell you and how much
was it sort of like oh you're making a
series and you want me to be a part of
it where do i side well that's exactly
it first of all lord and miller to me
are some people whenever i do uh these
interviews it's like well who do you
want to work with i'll be like well lord
of miller cause i'm a huge fan of
animation i'm a huge i was a huge fan of
cloudy then lego movie blew me away and
there so 21 jump street and everything
they've done so i always want to be
directed by them so he had texted me and
he said hey i'm doing this thing you
might if we talked i was like yeah of
course like it didn't even matter what
he said i could have been playing like a
chair hey you're gonna be the voice of a
chair in this one whatever he wants but
he told me hey this is what it is it's
gonna be like it's a whodunit and um
each person has their own little genre
when they're retelling it and i said oh
what's mine he goes and yours is going
to be a musical and i was like are you
serious he goes yeah and so he had a
higher i said yes immediate of course
exactly what you said is right i'm no
dummy when i see someone who inspires me
i want to be a part of the world um
copyright disney a part of your world um
and so i um so i said that and then like
a couple days later he said oh can you
sing or dance and i was like you hired
me without even knowing and he's like i
figured you could i was like i can
figure it out and it goes great great
great and so that was it it was heaven
every everything about this project was
such an inspiring wonderful time i had
the best time
your episode uh the musical episode is
spectacular and one of the reasons it's
spectacular is because the music is so
good the songs are so good so talk a
little bit about uh i love that like
there's a song called uh you only get
one shot twice yes two shots
right exactly so um talk a little bit
about the music in the episode because
like they're catchy songs
they're amazing the lyricist was
incredible and then and then chris and
uh chris and phil added a bunch of flair
over there and then beyond that to help
me sing it a fiora cutler who's like a
person who deals with people's voices uh
help me out so i can kind of learn how
to sing it in the correct way and then
um
and then kat burns who's a choreographer
who does like actual choreography would
like it's so funny she'd be like okay
then you do this and she'd slowly take
me through everything and then the
dancers would come in and she'd be like
okay everybody so it's gonna be a banana
split a five top with three four six and
you guys ready for i say except and they
knew it immediately because they're all
geniuses so it was me kind of learning
baby steps i've never done a musical
before and learning how to do all these
things um but the lyrics are incredible
because look at lord of miller's movies
they've done songs before they know how
to nail them and um it was just it was
just awesome and i felt very protected
because chris is collaborative and
lovely and wonderful and kind so i knew
he would take care of me no matter what
um and it was exciting and the fact that
like
so we recorded it over a year ago and i
haven't been able to talk to anybody
about any of this so the fact that like
you've seen it and you're like hey it's
good i'm like oh thank god great okay
good good it's like it makes me so happy
uh
the chemistry between you and sam in the
series is i loved it like you guys are
so great together especially like that
high school episode there's just a lot
it's just great between you guys how
much was that uh just talk about working
with him and just like bonding with him
on camera because it's so good
he's incredible so i never worked with
him before i never really met him in
person before so but i ha by the way i
did develop a show and i tried to get
him in it but he was busy back so i
already loved him like i wanted to get
him in a show that i was developing
years ago and it didn't work out and so
i was very aware of him and i love
detroiters and i love that he does
sketch i love that he does improv and
all that stuff and so we had never met
each other we didn't even do the table
reading person because of covid so the
first day i actually met him was when we
were on set together but because we both
have improv backgrounds it was
immediately
perfect we were doing bits with each
other it felt like i knew him since i
was in high school we were sharing
things about each other with each other
and it was just amazing he's an
incredible
actor but he's insanely funny he's so
funny that you just want to like i mean
if you watch veep he stands out in a
team of some of the most talented
comedians in the universe so it's i'm
beyond inspired by him and could not
have been happier to play his best
friend
uh each episode as we've talked about um
is a different genre and i'm curious
what was your favorite genre episode
that was not your own
great question i really liked jamie
dimitrio's uh throwback episode i
thought that was so fun and i really
loved
being the best friend romantic comedy
best friend because i love ducky growing
up in movies so it's like so like i love
that character i know what that
character is i can access it i thought
john cryer was amazing in that role so i
was like i love the idea of being like
come on man you could do it you know
stuff like that so i love leaning into
the cheese of that and then coming back
and doing this and being in an action um
but i'd say jamie's because we get to be
like little kid versions of ourselves
and then um uh the romantic comedy of
sam
did you actually before you got the
script for the eighth episode did you
predict who the killer was gonna be did
you get it right or were you way off
time i read an episode i thought i knew
it every single time i read episodes
like okay it's this person oh [ __ ] okay
maybe it's this person and i kept going
back and forth by the time i got to the
eighth episode i thought it was like
three three people three or four people
or i was like or maybe chris is just
like really screwing with us
and it's someone that i'm not even
thinking about but i i did not have it
down i did not have any idea who it was
going to be
i am still torn between it being one
person or multiple i i mean the thing
that that's so good about it is he has
set it up that it could be literally
anyone he's like it's such a good job
that's so hard to do he did such a good
job
um i before i run out of time with you i
am what we call beyond i'm on another
level of the concept of nick cage
playing dracula oh my god i'm so excited
i i mean i couldn't be i might be as
excited as you so i just want to know
how much did you pay to be in that movie
to work with him
so much money i mean so much money um i
me getting that role is so exciting i
got it
i think i auditioned and met with chris
before nick cage was attached and then
nick cage was attached all of a sudden
and then i'm like oh okay this is come
on please dear god i hope this works out
this is also gonna be very fun if you
and i have this interview we're
basically gonna do bc and ac because i'm
sure maybe you and i will talk for sonic
or space force and it's like before cage
and after cage because i've never met
him but i've been a fan for a very long
time and i cannot wait
to meet him and i have i have scenes
with him and his role is so good in this
movie the cast is bananas it's nick holt
nick cage aquafina and me it's crazy
it's insane that i get to play with that
group of people i leave very soon to
start that movie and i am
so excited you are going to go crazy the
script is amazing and mckay's going to
direct the hell out of it it's going to
be awesome
i've known chris for a while and i like
you know he had his choice of what he
wanted to do next after tomorrow war and
you know this was the thing he wanted to
do and i'm like what is it about this
but everyone's raving about the script
and the fact that he got caged to do it
you know i'm like oh this is why he
wanted to do the script is so funny it's
so funny and it's so cool and it's so
unique and different
it's just so good it's it's really it's
it's so many different things in one
um so we can't even talk about it for
real yet but one day you and i will and
it'll be and you're gonna be i think
you'll be thrilled because
cage is gonna be awesome in it
everybody's gonna be awesome in it my
most anticipated movie of the next few
months is unbearable uh talent you know
the trailer looks amazing yeah cage
playing cage
are you effing kidding me
i was so pissed i wrote i had this idea
that i wrote my friend uh jillian and it
was uh it had aspects of that and
they're like oh [ __ ] no we can't do that
um while i have you of course uh sonic 2
um uh i know tim miller and he told me
that it is way better than the first one
he liked it a lot tim
yeah uh and so uh i'm just curious uh
what you know he said it expands the
world and uh you know he obviously knows
uh you know what i mean uh so i'm just
curious what what do you want to tell
fans about it
um i would say this uh him saying i love
the first movie i thought jeff fowler
crushed it i thought the first movie was
awesome the second movie is just
epic it's huge it's big it's enormous
it's exciting it's like it's what
happens i guess
when your first movie does well you get
to make like an even bigger one for your
second one um
and it's exciting it's like a big old
studio movie and so i'm really excited
for people to see it and
i mean the expansion of the world comes
in our characters there's tails now and
there's knuckles now you know what i
mean and jim is on point of course so
it's it's really really good
and it's epic and i'm so excited for
people to see it because it's awesome
i have to stop there they were they've
given me the out of time signal so i'm
happy that we got to fit you in man if
you didn't tweet that wouldn't happen so
i'm happy we worked it out nice to see
you good to see you man
later
you